it's official alfonso ribeiro has danced
his way to a victory hey guys I'm Silvia
lacy with trending on 80 now even after
battling through some tough injuries
Alfonzo NAB's Dancing with the Stars
mirror ball trophy on Tuesday night ET
caught up with the actor and his dancing
partner Whitney after the win a few
dreams you know over the last 10 years
you know probably in the thousands but
you know something crazy both my mom and
sister both had a dream that we were
gonna win last night well that's a
that's a good dream yes yeah you know
it's gonna be fun I didn't want this
time with Whitney to end so you know
we're gonna go out there I know mark and
Val and Emma and Kyo and you know we're
gonna go out and have a great time and
take take Dancing with the Stars to the
people that is one who were we are
definitely looking forward to now
performances kick off on December 27th
with pros like Mark Ballas Emma Slater
Kym Johnson and Val Chmerkovskiy and
more dancing their way across the
country for a full list of tour dates
you can check out the Dancing with the
Stars website congratulations to Alfonzo
and Whitney and to celebrate we'll leave
you with a little Carlton enjoy
if you changed
I knew she would